[Música]
o trabalho não é sem querer é de
propósito
você já se perguntaram se você trabalha
sem querer ou de propósito porque muitos
de nós trabalhamos sem querer sem
vontade e sem intenção e de verdade
trabalhar sem querer
é algo realmente muito triste e por isso
que na minha jornada
durante toda a minha vida empresarial eu
resolvi trabalhar de propósito
então o trabalho não é sem querer é de
propósito eu iniciei minha carreira
fazendo arquivos de fichas de 8 mil
colaboradores em uma empresa em ordem
alfabética e eu era auxiliar de
documentação gente tá baixo de auxiliar
de escritório bem lá embaixo eu só tinha
uma intenção arrumar aquele arquivo e
todos os dias eu planejava olhava
verificava como eu poderia melhorar
aquilo eu levei um ano e meio para
arrumar aquele arquivo e quando a minha
chefe viu ela me disse
nossa nunca ninguém conseguiu fazer isso
e aí eu percebi que quanto mais eu
planejar se quanto mais eu entendesse os
aspectos técnicos do trabalho mas eu
conseguiria entregar o meu trabalho de
forma positiva mas mais do que tudo isso
eu também aprendi nessa fase que o
tamanho do meu cargo não diminuiria o
tamanho do sucesso do meu trabalho
depois disso fui convidada para
trabalhar numa empresa de embalagens
superar garrafas plásticas
eu entendia nada de garrafas plásticas
mas eu resolvi e chegando lá eu me
apaixonei pelo processo de garrafas
eu colocava o capacete na fábrica e
andar pelo processo produtivo e olhar
cada uma das fases do processo e
estudava estudava
foi aí que resolvi fazer minha primeira
especialização em administração
industrial napoli
para entender mais os processos
produtivos e de tanto que eu estudei de
tanto que eu olhei pra esse processo eu
inventei uma garrafinha pequenininha
para as crianças
e aí então nasce a inovação tudo muito
legal mas o que eu mais aprendi é que
sejam idéias pequenas ou idéias grandes
nós não fazemos nada sozinho e se nós
não contaminar mos as outras pessoas com
a nossa ideia elas não nascem depois
disso fui convidada para trabalhar numa
empresa número um de alumínio no mundo
um head ran ter me liga e fala olha nós
queremos oferecer 15 salários de luvas
antecipado para você mas eu era tão
apaixonada pela empresa de embalagens
que eu falei não não vou aí depois me
fez um novo convite eu disse não não vou
até que ele me disse algo que mudou
radicalmente a minha decisão e ele me
disse você vai ser a primeira mulher na
história mundial dessa empresa tem esse
cargo e eu disse eu vou rapidinho porque
eu não conseguia entender e nem imaginar
naquela altura da minha vida como pode
uma mulher não ter uma posição dessa na
empresa número um do mundo em alumínio e
foi aí então que eu comecei a lutar pela
diversidade de géneros nas empresas e
mais que isso pela representatividade da
mulher nos altos cargos de administração
simplesmente porque juntos somos
melhores
todos e com todos
para todos se não o sucesso não vem
depois disso eu montei a minha primeira
empresa no brasil e montei a minha
filial na china
eu comecei a ir para a china várias
vezes quando de repente desde o primeiro
dia eu vi os chineses entregando um
cartão de visita para mim e se curvando
aquilo me deixava até um pouco
constrangido na verdade eu questionei um
dos chineses mas por que vocês fazem
isso e ele me disse te entrego com
dedicação e amor o meu melhor
o meu trabalho e aí então eu entendi bem
cedo que se nós não tivermos a humildade
de ouvirmos o nosso cliente ou as
pessoas que entregamos o nosso trabalho
a gente não consegue entregar o trabalho
que deve ser entregue hoje eu sou
conselheira de empresas familiares e sim
fazer planejamento estratégico para o
futuro sem estratégia o que vais em
curto médio e longo prazos em monitorar
e sem incentivar essa empresa o
resultado não vem mas mais do que tudo
isso eu aprendi que sem ter diálogos
francos e honestos com essas famílias
o resultado não vem e até no meu
trabalho social eu sou embaixadora do
amor em cartas a gente escreve carta
para pessoas carentes de amor e de
afecto e esse trabalho se nós não
estivéssemos feito planos e planos
ficássemos dias e dias trabalhando em
cima disso planejando e organizando e
fazendo nós não conseguiríamos atender
às pessoas da forma que nós atendemos
mas eu aprendi que esse trabalho não me
deixa esquecer todos os dias da minha
vida que até uma simples carta eu
preciso de alguém para escrever e de
alguém para receber
liderei negócios no brasil e na china de
bolsas femininas alumínio fez negócios
totalmente diferentes
gente eu usei o telex e eu também usei o
fax
quando eu vi o facto da primeira vez eu
não dormi à noite porque como pode você
colocar um papel de um lado e sair do
outro lado aquilo pra mim não consegui
entender
depois usei o bip você usar o bife na
cintura e ainda era elegante e hoje nós
estamos com o iphone 8 aí nas nossas
mãos ou seja inúmeras mudanças globais
ocorreram na tecnologia na gestão na
forma de nos comunicarmos na forma de
gerir mos as nossas empresas novos robôs
nasceram a inteligência artificial fará
o que talvez hoje não possamos imaginar
mas tem uma coisa que ou seja na terra
ou seja na lua
nenhum robô vai fazer ter a nossa
capacidade de sentir e de pensar com
inteligência emocional
então no meu trabalho
mesmo usando facas e o telex lá atrás eu
não pensei como seria o futuro do meu
trabalho eu fiz o meu trabalho todos os
dias
de propósito com vontade dia a dia
mês a mês ano anos sem me preocupar com
o futuro porque as mudanças vão vir
mesmo
então mesmo que eu não utilize o fax
hoje mesmo que não utilize o bip eles me
conduziram até aqui e me ajudaram a
formar essa trajetória
depois eu fiz minha graduação em
matemática o que me ajudou muito nos
processos de decisão
e já mento na lógica e na razão mas não
me deixou fria para entender todos os
dias que o meu trabalho só seria um
trabalho de impacto
se eu deixasse uma marca especial na
vida das pessoas e nós só podemos
evoluir acertar e crescer quando a gente
faz alguma coisa por querer com vontade
com amor e com intenção e é por isso
então que eu desejo a você que você
sempre faz o teu trabalho - sem querer
mas mais de propósito
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]